[Musica]
[Applauso]
buon pomeriggio a tutti oggi parleremo
di fallimento parleremo di piano b ma ne
parleremo proprio nel campo della
sostenibilità
perché vedete quando si tratta di
pensare di parlare della salute del mare
degli oceani delle specie vegetali ma
anche del benessere degli esseri umani
così come delle specie animali
beh il fallimento si può veramente
nascondere dietro l'angolo e quindi è
molto importante
preparare o comunque pensare sicuramente
ha dei piani b ci sono dei brand molto
celebri veramente molto famosi da qui
non ci saremmo mai aspettati dai
fallimenti e invece hanno fallito noi
nel mondo della comunicazione le
chiamiamo epic fail proprio fallimenti e
pc e da cui insomma questi brand sono
uscite con un po di ossa rotte ne
vediamo alcuni vediamo alcuni casi
celebri che probabilmente già conoscete
xkè sono anche contenuti in alcuni libri
di testo o comunque si possono trovare
molto facilmente il primo è quello di
ryanair una campagna con un di
comunicazione pubblicitaria di qualche
anno fa che si colloca e si collocava
per diciamo nell'alveo di quelle
tecniche di comunicazione per cercare di
combattere il cosiddetto flight gaming
quindi tutta quella pressione anche
mediatica dell'opinione pubblica contro
il l'impatto ambientale delle compagnie
aeree dei viaggi aerei e quindi ryanair
ha voluto cercare di far capire quanto
fosse attenta alle esigenze
dell'ambiente e ha pubblicato questi
dati questa pubblicità dopo circa
48 ore pochi giorni è stata bloccata
dalle autorità pubblicitaria britannica
proprio perché considerata fuorviante
considerata non completamente veritiera
perché questi dati comunque riportavano
come vedete dei dei numeri delle
percentuali che comunque erano calcolate
sulla base di quelli che erano i dati
del settore low cost che è completamente
diverso rispetto invece al funzionamento
diciamo del settore della media del
settore aereo
se andiamo avanti beh come sapete come
avrete visto anche molti dei brand che
magari voi consumate che voi conoscete
avrete visto tante volte che
improvvisamente si sono tinti di verde
no hanno tinto di verde i propri peccati
o magari anche il contenuto relativo al
proprio prodotto e magari hanno anche
riportato sulla confezione cento per
cento green non è che stanno dicendo una
bugia non stanno assolutamente dicendo
magari qualcosa di non vero perché
magari sono green davvero sono diventati
verdi loro packaging piuttosto che
appunto i contenuti dei loro prodotti ma
questo cento per cento green a che voi
avrete letto decine e decine di volte in
realtà non ci dice assolutamente nulla
di quello che l'azienda sta veramente
facendo in modo autentico e profondo per
l'impatto ambientale o nel campo della
sostenibilità
quando poi si pensa al fallimento nel
campo della sostenibilità
dobbiamo anche pensare a un aspetto
molto importante ci sono delle aziende
che hanno comunque intrapreso dei
percorsi anche molto nobili importanti
nel campo della sostenibilità ma hanno
sottovalutato gli effetti collaterali
qualche anno fa
mcdonald's ha annunciato prima in uk di
voler sostituire tutte le cannucce di
plastica con cannucce di carta pensate
che in un solo giorno in uk vengono
usate più di 1.800.000 cannuccia
voi direte beh bellissimo passo positivo
nel campo della sostenibilità ambientale
sicuramente sì peccato che nel giro di
poche ore sono partite delle petizioni
sono state raccolte più di 60.000 firme
perché perché
le cannucce di plastica avevano già
comunque alle spalle un processo di
riciclo ben organizzato e ben rodato
invece per le cannucce di carta veniva
chiesto ai clienti di gettarle nel
bidone nella contenitore della raccolta
indifferenziata e quindi subito i
clienti si sono ribellate dicendo che
comunque prima di prendere questa
decisione sicuramente nella direzione
giusta mcdonald avrebbe dovuto cercare
di
prevedere gli effetti collaterali e di
gestirne ovviamente in modo positivo
ecco un altro epic fail è quello di
pepsi
probabilmente la conoscete è una
pubblicità che ha avuto un riscontro
fortissimo nella rete a livello mondiale
quindi un brand molto molto conosciuto
che anche qui ha voluto creare una
campagna pubblicitaria tra l'altro
eseguita in modo perfetto dal punto di
vista tecnico perché gestita da una
grande agenzia pubblicitaria e in questo
caso anziché parlare d'ambiente trattava
di sostenibilità sociale quindi diritti
civili quindi diritti umani e voleva
diciamo cercare di dare il proprio
contributo al movimento black light
smartphone cosa è successo è successo
che anche in questo caso in pochissime
ore milioni di visualizzazioni peccato
che la protagonista che qua vedete in
primo piano era una modella molto famosa
nel mondo social del reality show e
quindi era un personaggio accostato a
tematiche leggere non serie come quelle
della sostenibilità poi per cui questa
campania ha suscitato ilarità nella rete
e quindi avuto esattamente l'effetto
contrario di quello che mcdonald's
aspettava anziché far riflettere le
persone su delle tematiche serie
importanti profonde come i diritti umani
i diritti civili le persone ridevano e
in qualche modo deridevano le scelte di
pepsi quindi bisogna sempre stare molto
attenti soprattutto quando si parla si
comunica a comuni che la comunicazione
guardate sembra una tematica banale che
tutti possono affrontare perché in
qualche modo tutti sappiamo insomma
parlare tutti sappiamo esprimerci e
tutti sappiamo scrivere ma in realtà è
una materia veramente molto molto
delicata soprattutto quando si tratta di
tematiche così
così delicate per l'appunto allora il
fallimento nel campo della sostenibilità
sicuramente si ha bisogno come dire e
soprattutto è molto probabile in due
situazioni quando la l'azienda non ci
crede veramente
quando l'orientamento la sostenibilità
dell'azienda non è profondo non permea
il suo dna e suoi valori di fondo ma
anche quando l'azienda prende delle
decisioni in materia di comunicazione
che poi non rispecchiano veramente i
processi profondi e quindi non calcola
tutti quelli che possono essere effetti
collaterali e guardate l'opinione
pubblica voi lo sapete
in questa sala ci sono molti giovani e
quindi molto sensibili ai temi della
sostenibilità
l'opinione pubblica va a vedere queste
cose è subito le scopre il suo scrutinio
dell'opinione pubblica molto severo in
questo campo giustamente ma allora come
possiamo minimizzare i fallimenti nel
campo della sostenibilità soprattutto
quando comunichiamo e soprattutto esiste
un piano b io non lo so se esiste un
piano b sicuramente sì ma io vi voglio
oggi lasciare una parola una parola che
ormai è diventato un mantra nel campo
della comunicazione della sostenibilità
e questa parola e autenticità
ma attenzione non autenticità di per sé
autenticità percepita
quando parliamo di comunicazione non
dobbiamo mai soltanto pensare alle
nostre intenzioni noi possiamo avere le
intenzioni più belle del mondo
ma quello che conta è quello che
percepiscono gli altri delle nostre
intenzioni non è l'autenticità in sé è
quello che è percepito della nostra
autenticità dell'essere autentico bene
ci sono riuscite molte aziende credetemi
è difficile e complesso ma ci sono
riuscite molte aziende e di cito alcune
come per esempio dal d'affari al beauty
probabilmente una campagna che tutti
conoscete xkè è una campagna che è nata
nel 2004 e ancora oggi fa parlare di sé
ancora oggi una campagna viva dove il
fulcro non è più soltanto la bellezza se
anche la bellezza come fonte di fiducia
e non di ansa mail empowerment femminile
ecco vedete questa è stata una campania
che ha avuto successo perché l'azienda
veramente credeva in quello che stava
comunicando perché l'azienda ha fatto
power mentre femminile e della fiducia
nei confronti delle donne e della
bellezza autentica un vero e proprio
valore di fondo e tant è vero che questa
campagna quasi dieci anni dopo
a partire dal 2004 quasi dieci anni dopo
nel 2013 ha avuto più di 138 milioni di
visualizzazioni praticamente una nazione
intera poi ci sono ovviamente
aziende che sono talmente tanto per me a
tele sostenibilità ci credono talmente
tanto che si possono permettere di
comprare dell'inter e pagine di
quotidiani nel giorno del black friday e
di dire non comprare mio prodotto
addirittura questo subito dopo questa
pubblicità naturalmente patagonia
aumentato di circa il 30 per cento i
suoi profitti ma il punto non è questo
il punto che questa pubblicità è stata
percepita come autentica perché
patagonia da sempre promuove il senso
della educazione ai consumatori nel far
durare i propri abiti non non sprecarli
e fare in modo che i propri abiti durino
di più quindi una pubblicità ben
riuscita ma anche una pubblicità
autentica perché percepita come tale
finora abbiamo parlato di brand molto
famosi questo buffer non vi dirà niente
ma ve l'ho messo può semplicemente
perché è una piccola società di
consulenza nel mondo della del digitale
della comunicazione digitale ma per
dirvi che anche i piccoli le piccole
aziende le piccole realtà le medie
realtà devono orientarsi verso non solo
la sostenibilità ma anche verso la
l'autenticità della comunicazione buffer
quando è nato questa la sua pagina web
società di consulenza di sette persone
pochissime la pagina web era buffer più
trasparency tutte quei box che vedete
magari non riuscita a leggerli sono
tutte le aree in cui buffer ha voluto
fare trasparenza ce n'è uno che il
salario c'erano trasparenti i salari di
tutti i suoi dipendenti
bene allora che cosa vuol dire essere
autentici vuol dire che aprirci agli
altri ci conquista la loro fiducia e ci
protegge dal fallimento questo vale per
noi per le persone per gli esseri umani
ma vale anche per le aziende lo ha
capito bene scott cook fondatore di
tweet che ha fatto qualcosa di molto
strano di solito quando si va davanti ai
laureandi di harvard insomma pensate no
il discorso davanti laureandi di harvard
solito si impara dei propri successi e
si dice esattamente come si è arrivati
all'apice della loro cari della propria
carriera lui ha fatto esattamente il
contrario ha raccontato i laureandi di
harvard di tutte le volte in cui ha
fallito ha spiegato quando si è reso
conto di costituire un freno per
l'azienda quando c'erano dei compiti che
non riusciva più a fare quando si è non
è più riuscito a migliorarsi come leader
e ha capito che stava danneggiando
addirittura la sua azienda quindi abbia
aperto e in questo modo è stato
autentico ed è stato percepito come
autentico questo non lo leggete lo so ma
è un cv dei fallimenti andate a cercare
in google cv dei fallimenti e vi uscirà
questo il cb di questo professore
americano che ha deciso di
aprirsi disse per farsi per sentirsi più
vicino agli altri soprattutto i suoi
pari soprattutto ai suoi simili di farsi
ad apparire veramente reale e di
elencare tutte le volte in cui ha
cercato di fare un concorso era stato
bocciato ha cercato di guadagnarsi la
posizione di accademie non ce l'ha fatta
ha cercato di pubblicare un articolo e
non ce l'ha fatta
e questo tema dell'autenticità percepita
l'ha capita molto bene leggo quando nel
annunciato prima di tutto ha annunciato
al mondo che voleva sostituire tutti i
mattoncini in mattoncini sostenibili
voi sapete che leggo è un'azienda
fortemente orientata alla sostenibilità
e quindi ha iniziato a provarci non è
facile perché un mattoncino lego se ci
pensate è un mattoncino che dura
tantissimo nel tempo non si deforma mai
non cambia mai colore quindi trovare un
materiale che sia sostenibile e non un
derivato dalla plastica come come quelli
attuali ma che abbia queste
caratteristiche non è assolutamente
facile ci ha provato tentativi ed errori
tentativi ed errori fino a che qualche
anno fa ha dichiarato al mondo che non
ce l'ha fatta che non ce l'ha ancora
fatta questo non significa che sta
abbandonando l'idea
ammesso di aver incontrato tante
difficoltà di aver fallito dai suoi
obiettivi immediati ma che comunque
avrebbe voluto continuare a tentare a
riprovare nonostante i tanti errori cosa
dire quindi per concludere
quello che voglio dire che i cambiamenti
nel mondo della sostenibilità così come
nella vita
richiedono tantissimo tempo e questo gli
obiettivi si raggiungono sempre per
tentativi ed errori e questo noi quando
comunichiamo lo dobbiamo comunicare bene
dobbiamo far capire ai nostri pubblici
che è così
non dobbiamo fare degli annunci che poi
necessariamente sono degli annunci
magari anche molto come dire aulicino ma
che poi non sono percepiti come
autentici dobbiamo far capire i nostri
pubblici che la sostenibilità è molto
complessa che mettere in piedi processi
di sostenibilità è molto complesso che
richiede tempo
naturalmente e soprattutto che i
fallimenti possono essere evitati se ci
mettiamo un briciolo più di autenticità
e di sincerità magari le nostre parole
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]